hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to sins of a
father okay that was a little bit too
scary even for me but this is eternium
sins of the father a full conversion
Amnesia custom story that I hope you
guys all enjoy because it's been on my
list for a while to play I spread these
custom stories out quite a bit and it's
very highly reviewed it is exceptionally
I've only heard good things about this I
had been searching for days for the
mansion that I had tracked my father to
last having crossed multiple counties in
my
search oh it was on the 23rd of December
that I found it upon which I proceeded
to explore noticing multiple locked
doors eventually I found myself in The
Wine Cellar and the wind managed to blow
the door closed you know the wind that
rushes through these basements that was
when I deemed it prudent to leave before
this wretched man's collapse to top me
well finally we got a character with for
some common sense he doesn't want to
stick around here too long a large
barrel that stinks of alcohol of course
of course hello oh a note very good the
door's lock seems to be broken well then
can I throw something at it or do I need
to find a
crowbar I'm going to see a key do I use
the key for the office well I'm in the
wine seller so I don't assume this is
going to work but either way this one is
exceptionally highly reviewed and
because of it's a custom story it's
going to have some custom content to it
bam friend oh sorry I got a little
excited when I get to break down doors
is very fun for me o nice purple glow
also did it mention that this was on
Christmas Eve so is this father that I'm
referring to actually Santa Claus and
I'm going to be confronting him for uh
killing all those little elves and
murdering all of his reindeer to a pulp
wait a minute that door oh oh oh oh oh
come on I thought I should grab a
lantern before proceeding come on I
thought I was going to be smart finally
for the first time I've been ahead of
finally for the first time I was ahead
of the curve and it snubs me fine
whatever then fine get out of here I
don't want to hear it anymore I just
want to play some Amnesia get the pants
scared off of me and I am actually
wearing pants today so there's your
daily Markiplier pants update I should I
I do that I should start tweeting out my
pants status all the time no it's a
terrible idea why would I do that at all
that is literally the worst idea I've
ever heard oh sorry sorry about that M I
didn't mean to litter in your pond can I
go out there what is that is that a page
oh I want that I want to start my
slender Amnesia game and collect Pages
oh there's one in here Baron I write to
you in order to confirm your debt to us
as risen now I am sure that you are
aware that the cost before was grave but
now it has become so large that
unfortunately we doubt your ability to
pay it off thus we will arrive to the
mansion in 3 weeks upon our arrival we
will discuss various ways of paying off
the debt perhaps the Mansion itself will
be suitable as payment or you can
eviscerate our intestines and eat us for
dinner regards Thomas Cornwall cornal
Toral tnol wall
Lantern okay large oil potion Tinder Box
and I think that was actually the M yeah
cool that's is z Amnesia a Machine For
Pigs Lantern which means that this is
going to have some content from a
Machine For Pigs hello I was actually
expecting there to be a scare in there I
guess this game is not going to be
terrible hello you're the naked guy come
back come back here oh you handsome
devil don't run away from me how do I
get through here uh okay so I got the
lantern so I'm assuming I need to go
back that oh no one talk about that
nothing happened go about everyone just
shut up and ignore that ever happened
thank you very much so anyway we're
going to carry on over here we got our
lantern that it required us to have and
now we can go through yay I wonder why I
couldn't go that way maybe I'll come
back here later it can't be a terribly
big mansion this is only where Santa
CLA is he
right why do you keep interrupting me as
soon as I say things
oh good I'm underwater in
space okay bye just got to go oh God
what do I do oh I'm
dead
uh
okay oh good I actually am underwater
but the water monster was apparently
fake I think anyway so this is a going
to be game I don't know if I mentioned
but this game God I hate that I've got
the volume once again turned way up blah
BL what what what what what what what
what why I didn't see anything did you
see something did you get scared by
nothingness God what a baby you are ah
you're just the worst kind of things got
some nice mushrooms so I can go on a
drug trip oh I don't know if I mentioned
this before but oh man I recently got
the funniest emails I've ever heard in
my life um there was a
small there was a small very concerned
group of people and at first I thought
it was a joke but they were absolutely
convinced that I was addicted to crack
like not skip all the other drugs go
straight to crack because I this is why
I thought it was a joke because I they
had no logical explanation for it other
than that my hair was growing longer and
I was growing a little bit of scruff on
my face Ergo they thought I let myself
go I was in Los Angeles and I just
started doing the biggest amount of
crack and I was going to kill myself and
there were like letters of support and
amazing things like that and it was
oddly touching because they were so
cared they so cared about me but they
were so incredibly dumb but anyway I
just want to reassure you guys I'm not
doing crack I don't even know how to do
the crack if you know what I mean not
like that but anyway oh did I get a note
I didn't even notice I was on my crack
story The Rope here is frang I should
find some rope to strengthen it okay all
right I like that logic that is good
logic right there how about a brick is
this rope can this reinforce it oh no it
can't that's weird H I thought for sure
that would work well all right I'll find
some ROP somewhere else maybe under
maybe this bucket does this bucket work
no stop being stupid Mark God you're
such an idiot stop doing crack and get
back to the job okay so I got to find
some rope oh look rope yeah a I found
rope that's amazing right there for me
okay I actually seem to be doing pretty
good at this game because most of the
time I'm actually so disc concerned with
okay wow the change is okay I can't even
I can't even get kind of excited for the
amazing problem solving abilities that I
have I don't know why I should be so
proud of myself it was literally go here
put here and there put slot B and C
don't bang it don't put your dick in it
and then move forward and that was
literally the steps I took to get to
where I am now and look at me I'm a I'm
a YouTuber I do YouTube things wait is
there some oh ooh no wonder this place
is falling apart so why did you come in
here oh hello
[Music]
baby
pardon you w't run that by me again get
out of here I'm trying to flirt hello
baby how you doing could this be my
mother on oh crap I just flirted with my
mother it seems likely that my father
would have made a statue of her everyone
ignore that I'm doing everything wrong
I'm I'm on crack that's going to be my
excuse every time I do something stupid
it's cuz I'm doing crack so everyone
just ignore everything about everything
okay how do you even do crack I know you
don't I know you don't you don't snort
it cuz that's just regular Coke and then
crack is smoked I think cuz you need a
crack pipe yeah yeah I'm an expert on
crack apparently cuz there so
much okay so finally we're getting to a
bit of a better area in this Mansion
maybe oh good it's dark my friend for
nearly 12 years you have supported me in
my efforts I owe you a great deal but
the time has finally come that I make my
descent to find her I apologize for all
the sins we have committed together but
I know that it was worth it in the end I
also understand that some of your other
guests have expressed their displeasure
to my presence you're tall tolerance of
me was made evident by them and I cannot
tell you how much I appreciate this
regards your Tru friend Edward is Edward
my father Edward's my middle name not
many people know that but yeah maybe a
lot of people know that I have no idea
some people probably thought my middle
name was ier and that was where I got
marbler come from no it's much stupider
than that it's actually a combination of
Mark and multiplier and the story by
behind that can be accessed if you are a
very good Markiplier Watcher and you
have watched all my videos and listened
to all my historical babbling about my
life hello back there what are you doing
did I not see you over there hi what are
you doing hiding over there you don't
need to be
scared I'm a professional crack smoker
so okay
whatever don't do drugs everyone drugs
are really bad leave it to the
professionals yeah that's that's more
okay come on what have you got for me
game oh
so
scary all right what do you got it has
been 18 years since I last saw you my
love but I have not yet given up though
I am not sure what when I find you that
you will still look upon me favorably
the things I've done there's blood on my
hands sorry my love and no matter how
many times I scrub my skin raw the blood
do not wash away I can only pray that
you are merciful and forgive me of my
sins I contacted the orphanage recently
and they assured me that little Alex had
become rather garious and through and
through politician said I'm glad I
thought that what I had put him through
would have crippled his education in
childhood luckily it seems to have
ruined only one of the two which one am
I am I the ruined one I might be the
ruin hello I might be the ruined one
okay so that doesn't open up all the way
I either need to find a thingy thingy or
I need to find what is that why was
there a big old thing ah intense
moonlight so if there's something that I
need Moonlight for why are you here why
are you there why do you need to be
there what are you what is that oh it's
nothing I don't like all this nothing
all this nothing makes me rather
suspicious then anything Behind the B no
anything in here hello oh good dining
hall more notes having studied the terms
and Maps I have discovered that the king
off discovered a gantu Temple located
beow Yorkshire I think that this Legend
may be linked to the cult I proposed a
mining operation here as further
research has made me come to the
conclusion that Mansion May reside over
an
entrance okay the tests I have been
taking have been successful as of late
the workers no longer relying on sleep
to such a degree as before as well as
their strength being Amplified
considerably however I also find the
mental condition is deteriorating at
first there were some cases of minor
amnesia but now they are subject to fits
of rage and suffering panic attacks
occasionally it should go without saying
that this makes them extremely dangerous
I would suggest from a professional
standpoint to terminate the operation
and start over despite how far this
would set us back Dr
Brawn well that is absolutely
unacceptable we must
persevere how would this okay I'm
assuming that this kid was sent to an
orphanage because he must be hunting
down his father because what he did to
him and he wants to get revenge or I am
the messed up one and blah blah blah I
don't know what I'm doing with my life
anymore oh listen it's the sultry sounds
of my death wow
oh which way are you coming from oh hi
Hi friend let me just play a rag time
out of here don't kill me or you'll be
screwed I've got a problem with your t
why don't you go away and shove it up
your bum and then I'll go home and bang
Mo Mom Hi friend Hi there goodbye okay
bye geez wow
rude rude okay so I think he's coming to
say hi what a nice dinner guest one of
those servants who are extremely
dangerous but not to me of course I am a
gregarious son I've been told so warm
and cozy just like the inner cackles of
my heart where did he go
where did he go I know
that oh someone wants a second
playthrough someone loved my singing so
much that they want to hear it
again oh oh oh oh oh oh oh books books
that I can move with my hand the most
exciting thing ever I can't believe I
found that that's amazing oh this is
where he bed through it but he didn't
pass through it all the way how did he
get through must be a thin guy needs his
protein these just are doing some squats
bro I thought he might have been in
there but maybe I will be required to
hide in there oh hello I glimpsed the
key back there maybe important what are
you talking about I didn't Glimpse no
key and I'm very observant about
glimpsing keys where did you glimpse a
key okay where was the
key where was it hello is anybody going
to kick me oh here was the key you
didn't Glimpse that what were you
glimpsing okay so I got the key and I'm
going to just continue forward I'm not
going to make any obser okay that's just
a candleabra I don't need to be worried
about it I'm not a scaredy cat and
afraid of small tiny itty bitty things I
didn't even use the key well I guess I
didn't need it in the first place my GI
my giant muscles were able to get me out
of here wait why was I locked in I I
went up there hello
Mom hi sorry about flirting with you
earlier my apologies ow my legs are
broken can you help them my arms are
broken can you help me never mind only a
few people will know what I was talking
about
there okay wait what the hell sell's key
looks like that's supposed to be the
seller what else is this supposed to
be there we go oh wait no no the key is
jammed in the lock it must be the rust
on it well [__] where's Tiny Box
Tim oh I wish I had Tiny Box Tim here he
would help me he would make me feel
better I'm So Alone Oh was I supposed to
go here wait is that the way I came from
or is that a different
direction oh this looks new wait have I
not been using my Lantern this whole
time the other place was actually lit so
I I didn't really need it
ooh well this reminds me of a level from
uh the original Amnesia this looks dead
exactly like it or am I just losing my
mind am I having a weird Deja Vu here
God I have not played the original
Amnesia in forever I imagine that if I
did play it again it would probably
still scare the pants off of me my hands
are stained filthy I'm still talking
about my bloodstain hands the blood of
this innocent servant said I persuaded
my loyal friend to let me abuse he who
elected to shelter me and support me and
I have involved him into my sins may God
be merciful to him as I know the throngs
I have made him do I know them too well
the only hope the only piece of humanity
I've left is lost down with those
wretched beasts those cultists that
stole her from me I shall find you my
love even if I and others have to die
isn't my father just a standup gentleman
what is with these stories of people who
are so unbelievably obsessed a from
what air from the service comes from
here feeling like some Sinister creature
breathing why do you know what that
feeling is how do you know it's a
Sinister creature what if it's a
friendly creature breathing it just
happens to be really big and breathy it
needs a lot of air never mind I'm not
going to make any leaps of logic here
cuz as we know I'm an idiot and I don't
know what I'm
doing in Life or
anywhere oh what do I do my experiments
I have discovered the rust and other
such materials can Beed by acid however
be aware of using any your organic
materials weak through the flesh okay
hin put that in the thing
okay come on I'm going to get you I'm
going to dump ACI it on your face you're
never going to be pretty
again
okay am I staring at
something am I staring at something what
am I looking at I don't see anything
what are you talking about what are you
talking about I don't see what I'm
looking at I don't
see
what am I looking at what am I looking I
wasn't looking at anything what are you
doing [__] with me son of a oh he's
up there oh he broke the stairs hey
you you jokester oh get out of here ah
get out of here oh it's so silly okay so
I saw this this really is like the first
one because I do remember that this
exactly happened before and I was able
to cheat it because I was able to pick
up some uh-oh I was able to pick up
something and just be able to plant it
on there I can actually do with barrels
I remember but I don't know if I'm
supposed to do that or if I'm supposed
to go in here for some
reason
no okay all right I'm just going to go
up then thank you thank you for trapping
me here dick how about you go and have a
lovely L where did you
go is somebody hiding in the closet oh
oh I don't know where he
went ah oh is somebody in there is
somebody in
there okay I'm just going to assume that
he doesn't want to be found oh did
somebody lose an arm is somebody hungry
all right fine the guy doesn't want to
come out to play well he doesn't have to
cuz he can just be a dick bag by himself
care whatever I don't care why would I
care why do I care about where my friend
is whatever
bye have fun in the closet alone why
can't I open
that why is there fire on the other side
of
that wait wait a
minute wait a minute hey I got some
questions for you open up I need to talk
to you oh
key
I knew that was going to
happen okay we're done now we got the
hydrochloric acid and now we can dump it
on the
doad I think why do I have a chemical
container if I can't do that yay why do
I have a chemical
container why do I have a yay okay I did
that but I still don't know why I have a
chemical container unless later on I'm
going to pick up for more
chemicals maybe I don't know all right
whatever I'll find out that later when
it comes to it okay father please
explain your sins to
me I'm just a little bit confused about
certain subjects you know your wife may
be dead and my mama that I never
met that I totally don't have an edus
complex about but you
know it not worth it not worth doing all
this dastardly Deeds for okay well isn't
this lovely at least they're giving me a
lot of
H hey nobody likes you you get the hell
out of here clunk all right let's see
where are you boy they're giving me a
lot of oil I don't know if this Lantern
just eats up oil faster than any other
or uh do I need to find a way to break
through here
probably okay you son of a [__] let's
dance let's do the Tango we have struck
gold or rather bricks it seems your
guess may have been correct after all we
seem to have found a rather old very
worn down Corridor the actual structure
seems to be intact however we will need
some more equipment in order to safely
excavate the temple ruins overseer
Daniel Daniel from Amnesia probably not
I think this actually is much farther in
the future than that last one was um
anything in here anything important am I
overlooking strength strange keys that
are just lying on the ground is there
something behind here that I need oh
look there is and now I will die because
this looked oh look it's my death it's
my death friend oh hi you don't see me
I'm like a shadow in the night except in
Shadow in
the shadow in the broad daylight no
don't come back there's no reason to
come back fine you want a Tango you want
a goora come on bring it oh that didn't
work oh no you missed huh what oh oh it
goes right through you do I go right
through you are you really just fake ah
okay I'm gonna go this way now goodbye
goodbye friend
goodbye I thought I had it at last this
is the way most friendships go it is a
shame but I will have to forget him
because there's so much blood and crack
on my hands
whatever anybody
home anybody want to
play don't know why it started me all
the way back here bad death recover
mechanics is he still there or is he
gone forever is he actually going to
spawn
again I thought they did fix that in
Machine For Pigs where if you did get
killed by a thing and not that I got
killed by anything that often in my
playthrough but if you got killed by
something it actually did respawn the
enemy so I don't know if this one does
that as well death oh he's gone my very
good friend is gone what am I going to
do well he wasn't very good to me anyway
not like you guys you guys are the best
the best friends I could ever hope for
ding okay so where am I
going um oh come on have I been crawling
through this for no
reason can I throw something at it no I
got to go back son of a [__] all right
fine if that's the way you want to play
it
hello
hello is anybody here is anybody
home what is that is that a speckled DF
is that something is that the gold I
struck
okay nothing is there any point for me
coming down here oh come on don't tell
me I just got lost here for no reason
why was I crawling before oh I didn't
know I could stand up I thought I tried
that oh where am I going what am I doing
what am I doing with my life I don't
even know anymore I remember the spires
of Cathedral striking the clouds is this
really the appropriate time for this
memory okay what the hell I can't move
oh those are great those are
fantastic this is just the best memory
right
now the warmth of the sun upon my
face oh okay so enough ecstatic Glee for
a little bit okay now I do have to crawl
I'm pressing the not crawl button but oh
well anybody in that hole anybody could
jump out at me anybody going to startle
me oh crap that consumes a lot of oil
that is going much faster than I
remember is that an exit please tell me
that's an exit and I'm not going to have
to backtrack through those tunnels
again anybody oh note good I can't read
this okay that was that was cool I'm
glad that I did that we have encountered
certain problems with regards to
discoveries made within the initial
excavation certain areas of the rock are
near solid iron we need a stronger
acidic solution in order to overcome
these obstacles I suggest using sulfuric
acid it should do the job
efficiently okay then why hello is there
another monster in there are you hiding
there you little rap scallion you well I
hope you don't pop out and kill me cuz
that would just be the worst so I need a
stronger acidic solution which is for
this chemical pot stop conducting
experiments anywhere you bloody please
with your bloody hands this workstation
is here for a reason put containers and
other such things here I'm assing you're
talking about the chemical container
that I have right
here can I use this item this way it
looks like I should be able
to there's something
there okay so that's a glowy glowy and I
need to be able to use something with
the glowy glowy sorry were you drinking
that what is that Rumble that I hear
what is that on the ground that I see
what is bubbling up there is that
something I need ah come on on that
looks so cool never mind then fine I'll
just carry
on assuming nothing bad is ever going to
happen to me oh God another locked
closet I know what you're going to do to
me recently I have found that our
subjects seem to be harboring a hatred
of my lordship's guest and knowing what
happened to them I can't blame them a
small part of me hope said do kill him
for what he's done his sins must not go
with that punishment oh so you weren't
such a very good friend to this guy fine
be that way I must find my father I must
find a way to get to the acid to
dissolve this solid Iron Rock I'm
assuming that's what that is why not
just blow it up Surly it wouldn't be too
bad blowing up things underground so
far I can't seem to get by this wood
what do I need to
do what do I need to
do okay there's no lock upon the door
but I can feel feel some strange
throbbing from behind the door
H that that feels strange that is a
strange throbbing let me get my eye
closed to that that door is strange oh
wait it's a ooh what do I see what is
that ooh is that something I need oh oh
I got sulfur what is that what do I do
with it what do I do with over okay so I
checked everywhere there was absolutely
nothing more so you guys get to watch me
go through and find my way through the
tunnels again to me singing you a lovely
tune oh I'm walking through the tunnels
I'm going very far I'm going to go away
and die and then I'll get eyes Place
through the CL where the kids went to
die and then they stay there forever
like Neverland peteran and then there
was some weird thing where they could
have the an for Harry Potter or
something like that or maybe it was
something else I don't know but it was a
fun story anyway hope you all are
enjoying this because I'm l h okay
please tell me that this sulfur was
something that I
needed a
what do I do what am I supposed to
do that's what I supposed to
do no it can't
be it can't be oh my God what
no no you do not it took me far too
long I will not be defeated by the legs
[Applause]
of I handled it as carefully I dumped it
all as quickly as I could on it you're
welcome everybody you're
welcome okay now where do we go now what
fresh hell do we discover in the depths
underneath the castle what do I do where
do I go what do I need to do I didn't
know that I needed to set the chemical
pot down but then again I needed to self
for any way to make that work so I
didn't like I oh I'm not even
moving
father it's time to think on your sins
oh boy oh come
on
what are youing
me there somebody going
to
no there better be another part of
this
no no
no remain calm only authorized personel
pered to UC
elevator okay I have no fuel Rod so let
me just slam this soner
down what
happened he's right there where did he
come
from